good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this morning
you wake up to some very disturbing news
a gunman has killed 21 people at a
primary school in texas the victims
include 19 children aged between 7 and
10 and 2 adults at least one of them was
a teacher they were preparing to start
their summer break this week killer has
been identified as an 18 year old who
was armed with a handgun and an ar17
semi semi-automatic assault rifle police
shot him dead at the scene
a visibly emotional president biden
asked where is america's backbone when
he said in god's name are we going to
stand up to the gun lobby we'll be live
in texas for you it's wednesday the 25th
of may
america's 27th school shooting this year
19 children and two adults are shot dead
by a teenage gunman
one of the victims was a teacher named
as ava mireles and said she loved hiking
and was the fun of the party
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
also had sugray's report into how
lockdown rules were broken in downing
street is expected to be published today
what this report by sue gray tells us
about boozy parties in downing street
when the rest of us were told to stay at
home could define the prime minister's
future
commuters face a summer of chaos and
cancellations as well where workers vote
overwhelmingly for a national strike
and we have an eyewitness report from
inside a ukrainian city now almost
surrounded by russian troops
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world
from an orphanage to a peerage we'll
speak to simon wooley about his journey
from a leicester council estate to the
house of lords
and his plan to inspire black kids
and we'll also be joined by a young
ballerina who's sashing her way to the
royal ballet school
[Music]
hello everybody very good morning to you
a gunman has shot dead at least 19
children at a primary school in texas at
a news conference the state governor
said he shot and killed horrifically and
incomprehensibly it's believed that the
teenager killed
teenage killer's first victim was his
own grandmother before he drove to the
school armed with a handgun and an
assault rifle a teacher was also among
the dead
the attack happened at rob elementary
school in uvalde around 270 miles west
of houston the school has around
475 pupils our u.s correspondent greg
milan reports from texas
the robb elementary school has now taken
its place alongside sandy hook columbine
parkland
yet another school shooting to haunt
america this time primary school-aged
children killed in their classroom
the faces and the names are different
but this has become an awful fact of
life in america
the first of the victims to be
identified was teacher eva moreles
herself a mother wife of a policeman a
career educator who was very loved
according to her family
the white house flag was lowered to
mourn the lives taken
a president and his wife a teacher
herself of course wrestling with the
horror and the helplessness
in elementary school
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders
and how many scores of little
children who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
this is the gunman who was responsible
salvador ramos bought the rifles on his
18th birthday he crashed his car before
entering the school around midday moving
between the classrooms until he was shot
dead by a police officer
my heart was broken today
we're a small community
and we will need your prayers to get us
through this
uvaldi in texas is now the scene of the
deadliest primary school shooting since
sandy hook almost 10 years ago
many believed that massacre of six and
seven-year-olds would change everything
it shames america that nothing has
changed
but once again the calls for gun control
come
by doing something
we at least
stop sending this quiet message
of endorsement
to these killers whose brains are
breaking who see the highest levels of
government doing nothing
the grief is unimaginable for the
families of uvalde but this is the 27th
school shooting this year in the united
states
a country wondering what it will take
for anything to ever change
and the 144th mass shooting in america
so far this year more mass shootings in
the us so far this year then there have
been days in the year greg is joining us
from texas but the gun lobby is so
strong
in america isn't it great good morning
it is so strong and i mentioned sandy
hook there and of course that that with
the loss of those 20 young lives nearly
nearly 10 years ago
i think that that still is a lesson for
many people and joe biden was the vice
president and sat in the senate chamber
when the attempts then at pretty modest
gun control measures dealing with
background checks even that failed after
those 20 young children
six or six staff members at the school
even after they died america couldn't
and their politicians couldn't come
together to come up with with something
that deals with this and here we are
again and i don't think there's great
place
in america now that even this will
will um
result in anything different and you
heard joe biden there imploring america
and his politicians to come together to
stand up to the gun lobby he talked
about the fact when there was an assault
weapons ban here that the number of mass
shootings did go down
talked about the fact that other
countries have the social problems of
domestic violence or mental health
issues or people who are lost in society
they have the same problems but they
don't have these mass shootings because
simply they don't have the access to
guns things that seem very obvious to
everybody
but but still um
still it seems
won't prompt politicians to take the
actions and and all the time of course
we think of the personal tragedies for
those those families who lost so much uh
last night and the investigation
continues into that and and the morning
as well for this this small town and and
the fact that uh two days after two days
from now these children would have been
on their summer break which is a lot to
think about for those families and
everyone i'm sure uh watching this news
now
indeed so and we know that at least as
you said at least one teacher has lost
their life as a result of this gunman's
actions um
it's spring break i believe at the end
of this week so a lot of these kids were
planning their holidays
they would have been yeah it's a it's a
small town spring break is is different
in different parts of the country but
yeah thursday would have been
uh the end of the the term monday is
memorial day which is a big holiday in
america and then they would have been
off for the summer which adds to the the
tragedy of
of how this how this has happened at the
timing of this happening and the
questions about the the person
responsible salvador ramos uh the police
say um is a is a local person he lives
in this town he gone to the high school
in in the same area he bought those guns
two assault rifle high-powered assault
rifles on his 18th birthday the first
thing he did on his 18th birthday the
police said was buy these
assault weapons they don't know what his
motive was um at the moment of course he
is he's he was shot dead by a by a
border patrol agent actually who didn't
wait for backup who went into that
school to end this shooting when he saw
what was going on so they won't they
won't know what from him directly what
the motivation was we know on social
media he had hinted at what he might do
in some messages he post posted pictures
of those of those weapons so that might
offer them some some clues as to what
lay behind
uh this um this awful assault and one
which again has left america are asking
all of these questions about how these
things happen here and how they can be
prevented
okay for now greg thank you
well america as you're just hearing
there from greg has some of the world's
most liberal gun laws the 18 year old
gunman responsible for the texas
shooting could legally buy a
semi-automatic assault rifle couldn't
buy alcohol until you're 21. the attack
is the latest in a series of shootings
this is the 27th school shooting as greg
said in the united states so far this
year last year the us experienced 61
active shooter incidents the highest
tally in over
20 years president biden has said that
since the sandy hook school massacre in
2012 there have been over 900 incidents
of gunfire reported on school grounds
joining us now is professor brian levin
he's a former u.s police officer and now
criminal justice expert at california
state university hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning professor it's it's
incomprehensible for a country like the
uk to understand the gun laws in the u.s
and it's incomprehensible to many of us
here in the united states because the
way things have worked is that gun
restrictions
vary from state to state so a state like
california for instance we had an active
shooter who got his gun across state
lines in nevada
and indeed you have referenced the the
ridiculous problem of violence we have
that is affecting our young people in
the united states young people 25 and
under the number one cause of death
right now is firearms that include
suicides as well
and listen to this
10 times the number of people 30 and
under have died from gun deaths than
they've done than have died from covid
during the pandemic
but
the fact of the matter is
there is no constitutional restriction
as of now
to limiting uh access to firearms in
certain situations but the political
lobby of the nra and its related uh
fellow travelers
uh has been an
unstoppable speed bump to getting
anything done at a federal level so
we're stuck with making laws on a state
by state level so whether it's new york
city or chicago uh or elsewhere
guns come in from other states or in
texas where last year the governor made
it easy for 18 year olds to get weapons
when here to four it was age 21 where
you had to uh had attained that level to
get firearms that age rather so uh yes
uh those of us who study this are as
astounded as our friends in britain are
um i believe that um joe biden has uh
recently even before this event um
called for um
fresh gun restrictions
we heard this of course after sandy hook
we hear it very often after mass
shootings in the united states and still
nothing is done what would it take
um what it would take is having uh
people uh at the federal level in the
u.s senate uh get booted out
at election time but that hasn't quite
happened yet because we are so so
critically divided basically 50 50 in
our united states senate
and we can't get any bills through
when there is that kind of division when
all the republicans
vote against gun restrictions and the
democrats generally vote for them it's
really a stalemate unfortunately and
that leaves the unfortunate situation to
fall back onto the states where it's
very porous because our borders here in
the united states do not require people
to get checked when they go from one
state to another
and is it am i right in saying that
this kid um can buy a gun on his 18th
birthday but he couldn't buy alcohol
that's exactly correct in the state of
texas yes and it's not just texas it's
many other states throughout the south
and rural parts of the united states
that's i mean almost unbelievable that
that that is uh the case so many mass
shootings in the us i'm just um trying
to look up the figures depends uh which
website you look at as to how many mass
shootings there have been already in
2022 in the u.s but it looks as though
there is more than one mass shooting
every single day in the united states
would that be accurate
uh yes it yes it would be now not every
mass shooting results in mass homicides
but the bottom line is uh
the fatalities in the united states are
just so much higher than our our friends
in britain have and in canada we're
really most of the industrialized west
uh it's insane but unfortunately the
political stalemate that we have here
prevents us from having a ban on assault
rifles like the kind we had during the
1990s which unfortunately is no longer
law here in america
well wonders what your forefathers who
came up uh
with the second amendment amongst others
would think of the interpretation of
that right to bear arms
i think they would think it's crazy and
here's why just bear with me for one
moment
the second amendment says 27 words a
well-regulated militia comma being
necessary for the security of a free
state the right of the people to keep
and bear arms
shall not be infringed they had
envisioned a decentralized
military force at the state level to uh
protect against tyranny from a large
standing army uh like the red codes back
then but unfortunately it wasn't an
effective military strategy and
eventually these militias which were
open to male 17 to 45 became the
national guard but this notion that
there's an unbridled right
to to gun ownership by anyone at any
time just doesn't exist even the most
conservative member of the supreme court
antonin scalia who authored the opinion
in the heller case in 2008
which gave individuals some type of
right to private and gun ownership in
the home if they were otherwise legally
uh uh okay as far as mental competency
and criminal records uh he he even said
that you're not entitled to a gun any
time anywhere and he was the the
conservative justice who wrote that even
with a fundamental right that is
protected by the constitution the
supreme court has held that it can be
regulated and uh that's the case here it
can be we just don't have the political
will to do so
professor thanks for staying up late to
speak to us here in the uk this morning
very much appreciated thank you
thank you
thank you i'm looking at other websites
suggesting there have been 212 mass
shootings in the u.s so far this year
there have been 144 days i'm sure you
can do the math
sue grey's report into how lockdown
rules were broken at parties in downing
street is expected to be published today
joined now by tony blair's former
director of communications that's um
aleister campbell um hi alastair thanks
for joining us on the programme am i
right in saying that you went up to
dunblane with tony blair when he was
prime minister
no he's leader of the opposition and we
went with john major who was prime
minister
and i think that was uh an incredibly
powerful signal at the time a
conservative prime minister going with
the leader of the opposition
to show absolute support for the
community of dunblane and i think that
that moment in a way is what justified
politically and helped politically
the legislation that we then brought in
when we were in government
um since when there's not been
uh i think i'm right in saying there's
not been a single incident
in our schools remotely comparable with
the sort of shootings you've been
talking about in america and if there's
one thing i urge you guys at sky to show
today scott you may already have have
shown it but the basketball coach steve
kerr i've just been watching his
uh his comments when he was doing the
pre-match press conference and he made
the point
they go through these things everybody
is tweeting their
thoughts and prayers and everybody's
saying all the sort of cliches that
people roll out of these times but the
kind of exasperation that comes through
and i think was coming through in your
your previous speaker as well it's just
i'll never forget that visit to dunblane
and seeing the sort of the coat pegs and
the coats hanging off the pegs and the
all the sort of paraphernalia of a of a
primary school but it led to change uh
and what seems to me about this what the
guy there called this stalemate in
america
and the powerful whole of these
right-wing
very heavily financed lobby groups is
just it's just horrific and it's killing
people
yeah the nra the national rifle
association uh let's talk about um some
of the challenges that the prime
minister is going to be facing today
finally we believe that we're going to
be seeing the report from the senior
civil servant sue gray but we basically
know what's in it so isn't it time to
move on now
well if we quote move on as these tory
tory mps keep saying
what it means is that we now live in a
country where the rule of law is not an
inviolable principle in parliament
where it is no longer a principle of our
constitution that a prime minister and
any minister should stand at the
dispatch box
and tell the truth and if they
inadvertently don't truly tell the truth
correct the record and that says to me
that these tory mps are now propping up
this guy
they are
undermining our democracy to an extent
that i don't think we've ever seen
so i don't think i think if we move on i
think we can say goodbye to the kind of
democratic system that we have and for
what for one guy's vanity and narcissism
and you're right that we know the basic
story because boris johnson has set the
basic story he said right at the start
there were no parties there was no
breach of the rules he was assured now
we know
not only was he
aware of breaches of the rules he was
breaking them himself on a systematic
basis underlining the fact that as far
as he's concerned rules and laws are for
little people and big people
people with power people with wealth
they can do what the hell they want and
every you'll probably have a minister on
later on have these people got any
self-respect whatsoever do they not go
home to wives and husbands and kids who
say to them i'm sorry you cannot defend
the indefensible any longer when you get
i think it's george eustis doing the
round how can these people defend
just play back play back jim k
some of the previous defenses that he's
made when they had a different line and
a different story
so it was wait for the police it turned
out he broke the law then it was wait
for sue gray and they say well whatever
sue gray says as you just said we know
the story anyway the guy is a liar and a
charlatan he's doing nothing for this
country in terms of taking the country
forward and the entire conservative
party is let me jump in aleister if i
mention this
sorry okay let me jump in if i may um
a couple of things really i mean
the prime minister was fined once not
several times so the police have looked
at this in detail and they've decided
that it was one uh fine that would he
should uh pay um you talk about
inadvertent
misleading of parliament he says he
didn't know at the time
and then as soon as he did know he came
back to the dispatch box and corrected
himself
he didn't correct himself he came back
and said sorry for the actions of other
people that's what he did and that's
what he always does and the point about
the single fine i'm afraid as sadiq khan
and others said yesterday the
metropolitan police have got a lot of
questions to answer about the extent to
which they investigated this properly
and also okay the one fine is enough to
sink this guy
because he insisted quotes there were no
parties
we know he was at them you don't just
need the pictures you need the testimony
of other people and i'll tell the other
thing that happens i worked in downey
street this would never ever have
happened under tony blair under theresa
may under i think any previous prime
minister this is johnson's character and
johnson's culture so i just don't
believe that when he says when the
police say
you know one fine i think that was them
just trying to get out of this very
difficult situation for them
okay before um
before i let you go um
what do you think is going to happen
because
it would appear that nobody else wants
the job
nobody is certainly challenging the
prime minister so it doesn't matter how
much mod is slung around in the chamber
of the house of commons and on radio
radio programs and tv programs like ours
still going to be in post next week week
after week after that
well i don't know if that's going to
happen or not but if that is the case
then you know i don't want to swear at
this point
time in the morning but this country is
in a very very bad way
if this guy survives having now is just
are we just to accept as a country is
this what our democracy has come to
a prime minister can break the law a
prime minister can lie repeatedly at the
house of commons dispatch box send out
his cabinet of lap docks to go out and
repeat it for him have we got to a stage
now where there are literally no
principles attached to the basis of our
democracy including the rule of law then
if that is the case we are finished and
tom dukenhart was absolutely right
yesterday what this says is we do not
have a serious functioning government
and if he was doing other great things
the economy was booming inflation wasn't
soaring growth was high none of which is
happening if he was actually leading in
the world if he was actually delivering
on the promises that he made at the last
election he's doing none of that because
the truth is the guy is amoral he's a
liar he's a charlatan he's a crook and
if those tory mps have not got the
slightest bit of self-respect and
integrity and honesty to look in their
hearts and look in their souls and say
are we really going to damage our
country in this way then they deserve to
be kicked out as well
okay um thanks for joining us this
morning aleister thanks a lot as uh
alastair campbell said it is george
huster speaking to us momentarily here
on the programme of course we'll bring
that to you around about half past seven
before that though let's bring in
tomorrow she's standing by in downing
street for us this morning um hi
tomorrow it's going to be uncomfortable
reading for the prime minister how much
notice will he get before we all see it
morning kay it certainly will be we've
had a lot of the details already we've
heard about late night gatherings we've
heard about suitcases of wine but today
we will get the full account the full
unvarnished account of what actually
went on at all these gatherings we've
been waiting for it for six months and
we're told it will finally come today it
is not with number 10 yet i'm expecting
it will be sent to them mid-morning they
will have a bit of time to digest it and
then the plan is for the prime minister
to do pmqs at midday to then give a
statement
talking about that report apologizing
to parliament he will then do a press
conference later this afternoon and then
he will address tory mp so i think he's
trying to get all the apologizing to all
the different key groups out of the way
today in the hope that he can move on
from this afterwards
number 10 are very much treating this as
a very serious official account of what
happened um i think they they feel that
some of the the stories that have come
out have been
they feel slightly unfair on them
they've been at pains to point out that
the people in downing street were
allowed to be at work during the
lockdown and that um the prime minister
and some others have have only been
fined once over some of these gatherings
but i think certainly the prime minister
will need to apologize for at least um
what we what we know sue gray criticized
in her initial report as failures of
judgment and leadership from the top and
last night we heard some of the first
eyewitness anonymous accounts of some
junior staff saying that the prime
minister was not only not telling people
to go home when these drinks were going
on but actively grabbing a glass himself
so the prime minister is likely to have
to clarify some of that i expect he'll
outline some of the changes of personnel
that have occurred in number 10 since
all this came to light a few months ago
i think the big question now okay once
sue gray's report is out we may well see
photos we may well see more details is
first of all can the prime minister
weather this especially by bringing
forward a package on the cost of living
which could come as soon as tomorrow and
secondly what about all those tory mps
who we haven't heard much from were
waiting for the report reserving
judgment what will be their reaction
okay for now thanks so much indeed as i
said hearing from george eustis
momentarily before that though we've got
some breaking news as far as chelsea fc
is concerned mark is here with us uh
nadine doris tweeting yeah that's right
okay the government has just confirmed
that it has issued a licence permitting
the sale of chelsea football club just
to recap quickly
roman abramovich the owner for the last
20 years sanctioned by the british
government at the beginning of march
triggering a three-month sale process
which attracted billionaires from around
the world trying to get their hands on
one of
england's most successful football clubs
the auction of chelsea was won a couple
of weeks ago by a consortium headed by
an american billionaire called top
bowling who owns the la dodgers uh
baseball team and uh an investment firm
called clear lake capital now
over recent days kate there had been
doubts about whether the government
would issue the licence which uh paved
the way for the sale of chelsea there
were concerns that roman brandovich was
in some ways trying to influence uh the
destination and the uh the way that the
two and a half billion pounds of the
sale proceeds would be spent
now that uh impasse has been resolved
nadine doris the culture secretary has
just uh tweeted saying uh last night the
government issued a licence that permits
the sale of chelsea fc given the
sanctions we placed on those linked to
putin and the bloody invasion of ukraine
the long-term future of the club can
only be secured under a new owner we are
satisfied the proceeds of the sale will
not benefit roman abramovich or other
sanctioned individuals i want to thank
everyone especially officials who've
worked tirelessly to keep the club
playing and enable this sale protecting
fans and the wider football community
and just very quick quickly okay the
timing of this is very important
because in order to play in next
season's premier league and champions
league competitions chelsea needed to be
able to register for those tournaments
by the end of the month or by very early
in june
the fact that this sale
will now go through with the uk
government issuing a licence
allows that to happen just one more
point the portuguese government because
roman ibramovic is a portuguese citizen
and the eu still need to approve this
but that is now regarded as a formality
chelsea fans can look forward to a new
era of ownership uh and put the uh
recent uncertainty surrounding the club
behind them okay mark thanks very much
indeed thanks for the update still to
come on the programme for you this
morning i'm going to be speaking to
former chief constable of greater
manchester police sir peter farhi on
whether the police's party gate
investigation went far enough
we'll speak to
the
secretary of state for the environment
that's george eustis ahead of the
publication of sue gray's report into
the number 10 lockdown parties
and also to an animal welfare charity
blue cross about what's behind the
recent spate of dog attacks
railway workers have voted
overwhelmingly to strike and the
prospect of huge disruption on the
railways could be just weeks away uh
joining us now fraser moored uh he's in
leeds hi fraser good morning could be
all sorts of problems for commuters if
this goes ahead
good morning kay there could indeed yeah
it's estimated that if uh if signallers
go on strike when these strikes are
called it could mean that services are
reduced to something like a fifth of
their normal
weekly rates it could mean 30 million
pounds a day being lost by the rail
network it could mean that services are
limited to maybe two hours of seven in
the morning till seven in the evening
and only on main lines so there's real
potential for serious disruption of
course people are only just coming back
to the railways after the lockdowns and
uh and after being forced to work from
home many people still choosing to work
from home and of course that's meant
that the number of rail fares are
dropping so it's a it's an industry
that's losing money the government says
it's been propping it up since the start
of the pandemic it can't continue to
prop it up and it's looking as though
they're going to have to cut their
funding by something like two billion
pounds that means potentially two and a
half thousand jobs at risk according to
the rmt they say that today's
endorsement of railway workers is a
vindication of their approach and sends
a clear message that members want a
decent pay rise job security and no
compulsory redundancies the department
for transport says that strikes should
always be a last resort not the first so
it's hugely disappointing and premature
they say that the union is calling for
industrial action before even entering
discussions the situation now is that
the union bosses will meet to work out a
timetable for potential strike action
and that could be as soon as the middle
of june
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot um actually i'm just going
to wander over and we'll chat to the
environment secretary who is um joining
us um now hi thanks for joining us on
the program this morning it's great to
see let's talk about texas first of all
though you've seen the terrible news
overnight and i was just sharing with
our viewers there have been more mass
shootings in the u.s so far this year
than there have been days in the year um
your thoughts well these are absolutely
harrowing and we've we've seen multiple
incidents uh of this sort uh over the
the years uh you know i've seen
interviews today with some of the
parents of
her you know parents who've lost uh
children to such you know terrible
terrible events you know and obviously
it'll it'll reopen again a debate in the
u.s about their gun laws um which
obviously are very very different to
what we have here
in the uk they have a very different
culture and a different approach there
but i i think for sure it's going to
reopen that debate for them
and thank goodness for that i'm sure
lots of parents will be saying this
morning um let's talk about partygate
should we um eyewitness reports we heard
last night
is it worse than you thought
well look i think we've known about a
lot of these events for some time though
that sue gray alluded to them in a first
interim report obviously the police have
investigated um all of these events as
well they gave the prime minister a
fixed penalty notice in respect uh of
one of them um and obviously we'll we'll
see what the final sugree report uh says
it's expected you know sometime this
week some speculation that it might be
today
um and we'll have to to see what the
final report is but look the prime
minister said all along he's given an
account of uh how he saw these different
events he's paid the fixed penalty
notice but he absolutely recognizes that
there were failings he's apologized for
that apologized for his role in that and
of course he tried to make changes
because there was a blurring of the
boundary if you like between you know
events that were happening just at the
you know the end of a working day in a
working environment a blurring of that
clearly to to what became in some cases
parties
you said um previously uh that uh some
of the allegations were over the top but
we're hearing from eyewitnesses
yesterday and we'll hear more i'm sure
today people of 30 or more gathering
from four o'clock they were having wine
time friday there were so many people in
the room that they couldn't all get a
seat so they had to sit on each other's
knees and the child's swing was broken
there was a karaoke machine the pm going
in grabbing a glass for himself um
do you still think it's over the top
well i never said um that those uh
clearly if you've got events like that
that's not uh you know that is not
acceptable not within the rules at all
how would you describe those the well
those those are clearly wrong and that's
why the police have issued a large
number of fixed penalty notices in
respect of uh some of those those events
um
the point that i was making is is where
you had instances for instance at the at
the end of a
working day people in a working
environment member of staff leaving they
might have had a drink and given a toast
to that member of staff in the office
environment to leave well that's
slightly different to to something that
then turns in obviously
at the time um well yes and i think
actually if it was a uh in a working
environment and this was simply at the
end of the day to send people off it
wasn't necessarily uh a breach but
obviously some well some of these events
clearly work okay and that's why they've
issued a large number of fixed penalty
notices yeah but the events that
specifically was talking about there on
the 13th of november the police did
issue uh fines for people that were at
that event so it was clearly against the
law and the prime minister was there
yes and look the police have obviously
looked at this far more closely than i'm
able to they've taken witness statements
they've looked at all of the evidence
they chose to issue a fixed penalty
notice to the prime minister in respect
of one of the events the one where it
was his birthday and people brought in a
birthday cake they've he's accepted that
he's paid that fixed penalty notice and
apologized for it the piece the police
will be closer to the detail of this uh
than than i am because i wasn't there
after all and um you know they've chosen
in this case uh not to issue a fixed
penalty notice to the prime minister in
that case and now as to why they would
have done that well they would have
based that on the evidence that they saw
and the statements that they took at the
time
the mayor of uh london has asked
the police to explain themselves i mean
do you think he shouldn't have done that
well look i don't think we should
question the operational independence of
the police um they showed very clearly
by the fact that they issued a fixed
penalty notice to both the prime
minister and the chancellor that they
were doing their work without fear nor
favor and
they've also issued a large number of
additional fixed penalty notices in
respect of some of these other events i
think we should you know trust and
respect their operational independence
in these matters although you didn't
trust the independence of durham police
and and uh many of your colleagues
pushed for them to look again at what
happened with kiersten some would say
it's one rule for one and one rule for
another
well um look it isn't there of course
there were people that um asked
questions of the police there were
police you know the metropolitan police
initially felt that it probably wasn't
worth going back to events that had
happened previously they were put under
pressure they decided therefore to look
at that i think people accept that when
you're talking about um uh you know
politicians people in politics people in
public life uh sometimes the police will
judge that that the public interest at
test is such that they they should look
at things in a way that perhaps they
wouldn't in other circumstances and
they've done that in the case of
all of those events in downing street a
very thorough examination of that and of
course durham police you know are
looking again now at that issue
surrounding kiestama but the prime
minister was presiding over a culture of
where 126 fines have been issued for
breaking the law when the rest of the
country was in lockdown people were
sleeping at their desks because they
were so drunk they couldn't go home the
child's swing was broken karaoke
machines as i've said you know we saw
the prime minister where there were six
bottles
of booze and a bottle of gin on the
table he was presiding over all of this
shouldn't he accept responsibility
well look i think he has and he he's
demonstrated uh that by the statement
that he gave to parliament when sue gray
published her initial findings she
highlighted the fact that there was a
you know a culture of drinking and a
culture that enabled the blurring of the
boundary between what was um you know an
acceptable thing at the end of a working
day with people working in an office
together during difficult times and what
was then becoming you know an event and
a party she said that they were failing
she highlighted that in her interim
report i suspect that a final report
will build on that and and and be quite
critical in some of those regards she
said there were management failings at
many different levels and she's already
made that clear and she's made
recommendations on how
the operation at number 10 should be
changed and the prime minister's already
been clear that he will implement all of
those some people so drunk that they had
to sleep on a sofa at dining street uh
while uh some members of the public
couldn't go to the funerals of their
loved ones
the optics of that surely the prime
minister should think i presided over
that i was responsible for what happens
in downing street
how can he possibly stay in post well
look it's not just the optics it's it's
understandable that people will feel
anger
because there were instances yes where
people you know couldn't attend uh
funerals uh of close friends that
couldn't visit loved ones and of course
we absolutely recognize that the prime
minister recognizes that that's why he
has apologized for the the failings of
number 10 and for his own part in that
he's come to the dispatch box several
times in parliament you know to
apologize for that he's paid that uh
fixed penalty notice he absolutely
acknowledges
just how angry people will feel
and and completely gets that and has
apologized for that but he still will
stay in post even though he misled
parliament
well i i don't think uh it's right to
make uh that assertion obviously there
is a you know standards and privileges
committee uh that is looking at that
particular allegation what have they
decided well ministers and politicians
are not supposed to knowingly mislead
parliament but the prime minister
himself was also given a very clear
account of his own understanding of all
of those events that he attended that he
didn't regard them as parties and he
didn't regard them as breaking the rules
he's explained that that was his uh
understanding
and obviously where the police have said
that there were particular failings on
his part uh in in respect for at uh the
birthday party whether the cake was
brought in uh well then you know he's
he's acknowledged that and he's paid
that fixed penalty but if the committee
finds otherwise that he did in fact
mislead parliament then he must go
surely well look let's let's let the
committee do its work i don't want to
get into hypotheticals uh here um you
know there are lots of parliamentary
processes
of this sort um he said fine let the let
the committee uh investigate this look
at it
but obviously they're going to want to
take evidence from him they're going to
want to talk to him and we should let
that process run its course and not get
ahead of ourselves
um we could talk about that um all day
but of course there was another couple
of things that i want to ask you about
not least
the
rail strike rail and maritime union
voting to go on a national strike um
you could i think i'm right in saying
consider legislation to ensure minimum
staffing levels in the event of a strike
that was something that was in your
manifesto is that something that you
would uh implement
well look obviously grant shaps is
working quite closely at the moment with
um you know the rail unions to try to
make sure that they don't go
this step um you know the truth is the
pay settlements haven't yet um you know
even been discussed there are some
important reforms and changes that are
going to need to be
made on things like ticket offices some
of which aren't really
used anymore and
they're not it's not viable to keep them
all open there are digital technologies
that we can use to make processes work
better to help passengers there are
technological things that will improve
rail safety but my question is would the
government consider changing the law to
ensure minimum staffing levels as was
suggested in your manifesto well of
course we don't rule any of these things
out but at the moment what we want to
try to do is to to work with the unions
and to get some constructive engagement
here with them there are some real
challenges facing the railways during
the pandemic huge amounts of public
subsidy had to go to keep the rail
network running with passenger numbers
down passenger numbers you know remain
down and that means we are going to have
to change the way certain things work
and change certain practices
we're not ruling anything out but but
you know um what i'm trying to say okay
is in the first instance in these things
you know obviously we try to engage
constructively you know with the rail
unions and the workforce in each of
these cases final question before i let
you go uh ukraine last night pleading
with the royal navy
to go
to uh odessa to try to stop that
blockade of the port we were speaking to
your colleague yesterday he said that at
grand chaps of course he said that if
that blockade continues more people are
likely to die around the world from
starvation than will die in the war in
ukraine are we looking again at the
royal navy going well look um there
aren't any plans to send the the royal
navy to the black sea however what we
what we are looking at is is other uh
corridors to try to get some of those um
grain stores out of ukraine
i understand there's sort of perhaps 30
to 40 million tons of of grain there
and that's um you know a significant
proportion of the current world stocks
which is probably around 230 million
tons it's very important in these
situations when you have
this kind of stress on the system that
you keep world markets open so that you
can move grain from the countries that
have it in store to those so overland is
that what you're saying uh yes but for
other yeah exactly so uh countries that
have put in place export bans for
instance that's very
you know damaging to confidence around
the world luckily all of the big
producer nations recognize this and
they're all keeping their markets open
so ourselves the european union the
united states we're keeping markets open
so that grain can flow around the world
but i know that there is some thought
being given by the g7 as to how we can
uh potentially get safe corridors to be
able to move uh some of those uh some of
those grain stores out uh by land okay
for now thanks very much indeed minister
much appreciated thank you it's going to
be a busy day for you uh now taking a
look at this morning's newspapers the
mirror leads with a new photo from an
event in downing street during lockdown
and us
why did the pm deny it it's the same
story in the star this morning it has
the headline party animals after
revelations of a social drinking culture
inside number 10 during lockdown
the eye leads with news that energy
bills are set to rise by around another
800 pounds a year in a few months as the
energy price cap is raised once more
according to the telegraph a windfall
tax could be announced within days as
boris johnson tries to put partygate
behind him
well the pm is bracing himself for the
publication of sue gray's full report
into those parties during lockdown
it follows the conclusion of the met
police's probe
joining us now is um
sir peter fahey is with us now actually
in fact hello to peter thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um
former chief constable of course of
greater manchester police they met under
a lot of pressure again this morning not
least from the mayor of london wanting
answers as to why the prime minister
only received one fine um
is it reasonable for them to have to
answer those sort of questions to to
explain themselves to the mayor
yes absolutely absolutely
and you know i think the mayor should
have got involved at a far earlier stage
and put in place a process uh to
actually provide confidence to the
public um you know he didn't need to get
involved in individual decisions about
who got fined but he could have put a
process in place um to actually help the
metropolitan police in terms of
providing some cover but the crucial
issue here really and i think the
minister almost said it is that the
legislation is very confused it was
simplistic it was rushed that's perhaps
inevitable in this sort of situation but
really people are looking for this very
poorly drafted criminal law to carry the
weight of political accountability uh on
the prime minister and the leader of the
opposition and that is you know very
unfair and can't happen there will be a
lot of anger today i think within
policing about this report uh president
dick lost her job she was sacked in
effect because supposedly she failed to
you know achieve a satisfactory culture
in one particular police station where
they're inappropriate um what's up
messages and the fact that there has
been this wholesale culture uh you know
in in number 10 downing street which has
angered the public um you know clearly
you know it has produced a lot of
cynicism but the fact is as i say the
police have had to try and do their job
um with this very poorly drafted
legislation and the minister said this
sort of blurred distinction between what
is an essential work purpose and when
that then becomes a social event
yeah it's so simplistic but i suppose uh
the simplicity of it
could be to the benefit of the police as
well because
you weren't allowed to gather inside
apart from work events and you know six
bottles of wine and a bottle of gin on
the table seems to i would have thought
most right-minded people that it was
more than just a work event and that's
why a lot of people got fines but um you
know in terms of criminal law simplicity
doesn't really help because it is about
the letter of the law um and undoubtedly
some of the people involved in this
exploited the the confusion and the
inconsistencies
and the ambiguities of that law when
they answer those questionnaires uh in
terms of that blurring um as to when as
i say between it being a essential work
purpose um and what was then a social
gathering the other thing you're seeing
here and it's reflecting in some of the
newspaper headlines is also this
confusion about what was against the law
and what were the rules and i think you
know the anger of the public is also
about the fact that there was so much
messaging every single day about social
distancing about not going out about
masks and clearly the police themselves
had to reinforce those messages when
they were dealing with the public but
the fact that you know the rule they
were they were rules they were guidance
and the police have to operate on the
basis of what was the letter of the law
in terms of this particular
investigation
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you
okay let's um take you to ukraine now
where the war has been going on for 90
days president zielenski has said that
he will only talk with russia's vladimir
putin directly not via intermediaries
alistair is standing by in odessa for us
this morning
hello to um aleister just hearing there
from the minister that uh although
ukraine's asking for the navy the royal
navy to help that with that blockade um
that's not going to be forthcoming
anytime soon
yeah okay well let's let's start with
that um development uh you'll see behind
me actually some of the grain silos in
the port here in odessa full to the brim
waiting to go but there's been no
merchant vessel activity here really for
the last three months and so that is at
the very source of what is now
a quite rapidly deteriorating global
food crisis and they are looking at ways
and means where they might be able to
get the grain out one of those would be
roads but any road movement of grain is
going to be a lot slower
than if they were to use uh shipping as
as would normally be the case but the
problem is you've got uh out to sea uh
at least 20 miles so beyond the offing
really the the russian naval blockade of
odessa which is stopping any merchant
vessels from coming uh in here so you
would need a military escort of some
description but then you have the
problem that if the british or or others
get involved uh from nato countries uh
then the russians might see that as nato
intervention so fraught with problems
there
but a situation that is growing worse
around the world particularly in places
like the middle east and north africa um
secondly in terms of what you were
mentioning uh in the introduction to me
about what president zielenski has said
this morning and the offer for talks if
the russians withdrew back the positions
they were in uh pre-february the 24th
just to clarify those positions were in
uh sort of the donetsk and lahansk
region in eastern ukraine i i don't
think that's going to happen i just
don't think that's a flyer with
president putin not least because the
russians have the momentum in the
donbass region at the moment they are
making progress which is you know not
something you could have said of the
russian military in much of the last
three months but they are making
progress they are pretty close uh to
completely capturing the entire entirety
of the eastern donbass region and i
think at the very least that is what
putin will want to do before he
entertains any uh potential peace talks
if that's indeed what he wants to do uh
what i do think president zielenski is
is right and saying is that
any
potential and i think it's not likely
but any potential that peace talks are
going to yield some sort of break in
hostilities i think that will have to be
done leader to leader but
so far that has not come close okay ali
for now thank you
well russia's slowly making some
progress in its campaign in the east of
ukraine the main focus of russian forces
is the donbass region to the east of the
country the area is made up of the
provinces of luhansk and donetsk both
seeing heavy fighting along their front
lines
savero donetsk is one of the last big
towns under ukrainian control but
russian forces are encircling it from
the north and also the south our special
correspondent alex crawford got into the
town over the last remaining bridge
its people are living under constant
russian bombardment
we're used to it he says it's been three
months
valerian his wife neela won't leave
they've notched up 135 years between
them and they're now enduring bombs
which are landing every few minutes
it is unrelenting and goes on and on as
he weaves his way back through his
community and takes us to his home where
he and his neighbors have been
sheltering and where he's been ferrying
food and water to
where there seems to be still a fair
amount of people living
his neighbors tell us how hard it is to
get even water
yelena's
[Music]
everyone begins to panic at what sounds
like cluster bombs landing far too close
by we head for the doorway to shelter
open the basement for larry shouts come
come he says i'm used to it everyone
piles inside waiting for yet more
incoming bombs
it was quiet for just 10 minutes every
day it's back and forth like this flying
over our heads
seconds later valeria's punched by a
neighbor he's angry at valeri for
bringing foreign journalists here
many blame us for prompting the bombings
this war has set pensioner against
pensioner and forced neighbours to turn
on each other
please tell the world what's happening
in donbass she says
what's she saying what she's saying and
show please have a tease
i'm trying not to cry she says i'm
trying to keep myself calm but you need
to tell them what the situation is
this is going on all the time
constant barrage it's unbelievable that
there are so many people who are still
living and having to put up with this
they're right in the middle of it
well you can watch
alex's full report on the sky news app
and also on our website
i want to update you on the news that
you're waking up to this morning that 19
children
and at least one teacher have been
killed after a gunman opened fire at a
primary school in texas
the attack happened at the robb
elementary school in uvalde around 80
miles west of
san antonio
we have the name of a teacher
who has sadly
lost her life we'll be bringing you more
on that in the next hour and also eva
morel is her name and also telling you
more about the 18 year old gunman
salvador ramos who has been killed uh
but shot dead by the police he bought
two guns on his 18th birthday this is
what the president said a short while
ago
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders
and how many scores of little children
who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
just put that into context the children
that have died are aged between seven
and ten
an eighteen-year-old came into their
school and shot them dead while they
were at their desks
i will see you at the top
[Music]
you